يبدو ان موجه الاضرابات في بريطانيا لم
تعد تستثني اي فئه عمريه اخر المنضمين الى
الفئات المطربه عمال سيارات الاسعاف الذين
التحقوا بزملائهم الممرضين المضربين في
وقت سابق الالاف من توقف سيارات الاسعاف
الخدميه والصحيه والوطنيه في بريطانيا
وويلز خاضوا اضرابا
تعبيرا عن رفض الحكومه زياده الاجور
اضرابات القطاعات الصحيه لا تروق بالمره
للحكومه البريطانيه حيث دخل وزير الصحه
والرعايه الاجتماعيه على الخط داعيا الى
تحكيم العقل مشيرا الى ان الاضراب ياتي في
وقت تواجه فيه هيئه الخدمات الصحيه
الوطنيه
الجيش في حاله تاهب للمساعده في قياده
مركبات الطوارئ
لن يكونوا مخولين بجميع الصلاحيات التي
تاع بها سائق سيارات الاسعاف
معنى من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
مصطفى اهلا بك يعني لو تجمل لنا ما الذي
يحدث الان هل بالفعل هذه المستشار
المستشفيات قد تم تعطيل حركه سيارات
الاسعاف بها ام ان هناك جزء من الممكن ان
يخدم المرضى او الحالات الطارئه
بشكل عام المستشفيات هي اهدى اليوم من
الايام العاديه بسبب هذا الاضراب للمسعفين
الذي يشمل ايضا الفنيين وايضا من يتلقون
الاتصالات من عامه الشعب لمن يريدون همم
سياره اسعاف بالطبع كان هناك جزء بسيط من
من قدموا هذه الخدمات وهناك فئه معينه
خاصه اولئك الذي لا تعرضون لسكتات قلبيه
هم في يعني الدرجه الاولى التي يتم
الاستجابه لنداءات واتصالاتهم بالاضافه
الى ان هناك ايضا بعض الحالات الصحيه مثل
همم الالم في الصدر يمكن التعامل معها
بحسب بعض النقابات ليس كل ليست ليست كل
النقبات توافق على على ان تتعامل مع الفئه
الثانيه من الحالات ولكن الفئه الثالثه
والرابعه ليست هناك اي اتصالات وقد واحده
بان حتى الاتصالات
يعني كانت همم يعني قليله مقارنه بالايام
العاديه وهذا مؤشر على ان الناس ربما
استمعوا الى نصائح نقابات وايضا يعرفون ما
يجري وبالتالي لن لم يتصلوا وهناك ايضا من
يقوم بهذه الاتصالات خلال اليومين المقبلا
وهذا لا يعني بان الايام ستكون عاديه جدا
لانه هناك مكان من كان بحاجه الى همم الى
معين من قبل همم المستشفى اخرها اليوم او
يومين وبالتالي اليومين المقبلان ستكون
هناك العديد من من اولئك الذين يعانون من
امراض يريدون ان هذه يعني داخل المستشفيات
يعني الى الان لم تظهر هذه المشكله بشكل
كبير اليوم هذه همم ربما الشدو والجد من
الحكومه والمضربين من سيصرخ اولا هل
الحكومه في بوادر استجابه ما هي بالفعل
متمسك برايها ورافضه لاي نقاش مع المغربي
ما ما يمكن ملاحظته عادل بان الحكومه
تحاول ان تلوم النقابات المصره على هكذا
اتخاذ اضرابات في وقت يعني حرج جدا
يعني بالتعبير بان همم وزير الصحه قال بان
النقابات اتخذت هذا قرار الاضراب بشكل
واعرض صحه عامه الناس الى الخطر وبالتالي
هذا اللون والتبادل لاتهامات بين الجانبين
لن يتوقف ولكن الحكومه مصره على ان تستمر
في تعنتها وان كان هناك اقبال او دعم كبير
من عامه الشعب اربعه 54% ايدون هذه
الاضرابات وان كانت همم كانت يعني بعض بعض
الحالات لن يتم همم
معالجتها او او النظر في في همم في حالتها
المرضيه والطبع هذا مؤسف جدا كما يقول
وزير الصحه شكرا